non non
non non non
j'ai trouvé la seule bande-annonce
valable à regarder je vous la montre
[Musique]
il y a mon fils qui vous a reconnu et
vous croyez que c'est possible de faire
une photo avec lui
on s'appelle
ça fait tousser
bonjour les tabac à force
quelques jours une sorte de séminaire
j'imagine c'est ça vous pouvez appeler
ça comme vous voulez ok d'accord des
vacances quoi c'est génial profitez bien
de ce séjour reposez-vous et surtout je
vous le répète travailler sur la
cohésion du groupe
j'ai attrapé avoir un
stress pour rien
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
faut que je dise à la caméra
j'arrête pas de penser c'est fabuleux
j'adore faire ça
c'est en étant soudé que vous pourrez
sauver le monde
allez qu'on en finisse on y va
j'ai trouvé cette histoire très
divertissante
[Rires]